[Music]
it's time to count down the best of the
bares and bus stops on Pi Morgan un
sensitive in 2023 wake up people because
no festive season is complete without a
good oldfashioned
argument well I'm asking who determines
do you get to deter it you get to deter
who gets to determine you to work out I
was coerced into this interview you
weren't coerced into this yes I was fine
if you want just shout at me that's your
program her your TV your show should her
Mass stay in power it's the question I'd
rather do it on camera no no no no why
we'll explain why you're are not
prepared to apologize to millions of
people for screwing their personal
finances you don't care about the little
guy billions of being murdered and you
don't care why you nuclear H if you're
if you're not against res why against
you let me ask the question I've done
this before this job let me do it I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your
questions welcome to the 12 ding-dongs
of
[Music]
Christmas and straight in at number 12
Popstar Sam Smith pronounced they there
for the moment was in the news this year
for a rather racy concert performance I
invited James Bar and Douglas Murray to
give us their uncensored review Douglas
let me start with you uh I don't get
this Sam Smith thing it just seems like
every week he
deliberately I'm sorry they even though
there's one there's only one of them why
why is s Smith they no please do address
Douglas first but I just need to
correct that's how they identify why why
is one person they because that's how
they identify why have I got to go along
with it because they've asked you to so
what no one asked me even the pope
respects people's pronouns now I don't
have to respect anybody's pronouns well
that's fine as long as that's your
decision my pronoun is hottest man in
the world yeah well I'm happy to call
you that some may disagree but yeah if
that's what you are then cool I will
address you as the hottest man in the
world throughout the entire inter
throughout the entire okay let stick to
that Douglas let's come back to you uh
you don't have to call me the hottest
man in the world even if you're thinking
it um Sam
Smith to me he's just on an Ever
deteriorating campaign to be as vulgar
and defensive as he possibly can am I
missing
something he he's doing what pop stars
have done for decades which is trying to
shock as a means to get publicity and of
course it's pretty successful I mean
we're talking about him at the moment uh
but it's it's striking that it's sort of
very unoriginal I mean all the stuff
he's doing the sort of O over sexualized
stuff the sort of satanic stuff Madonna
did this 40 years ago um uh you know pop
stars have done this and more for
decades now uh I think the only thing
that Sam Smith has got sort of going of
him on this and the thing actually is
making people notice him on this is that
first of all he keeps sort of throwing
these ballards in the way of everyone by
changing his alleged gender all the time
he came out some years
ago he came he came out many years ago
as gay and then he said he was actually
a gender queer and then he said he was
non-binary and he said he didn't know
what it meant of course he didn't
because there's no such thing but he he
said that they were going to uh he said
that he thought he was gender Quinn he
he didn't know what it meant but he said
that he would explain it someday when he
did know and I thought s of think if
you're going to make everyone else
distort the language you should know
what you're talking about first so he
does that to get publicity obviously and
the other thing he does is he does this
sort of um you know like taking all his
clothes off stuff and and the thing that
makes it different from other people is
that when oh I don't know Justin
Timberlake or Rihanna or someone
stripped down they do so because they
look good like their bodies look good
Sam Smith is like pudgy and very ugly
and so people look at it and he looks
for ridiculous and the problem is is
that he's saying don't ridicule me but
it's hard not to ridicule people when
they present
themselves what are you talking about
okay on that point I completely agree
why say don't ridicule me when you
deliberately make yourself look
ridiculous no that is disgusting that is
a completely disgusting is disgusting we
do find it disgusting what you're saying
is we're allowed to find it disgusting
no you are not you can't keep commenting
on what people look like all the time
you it's if they going dress like that
on a stage in front of Millions of
people around the world absolutely I can
thank you for getting the pronoun
correct I really appreciate that listen
did I Douglas yes you did well have you
called have you called me mine hottest
man in the world appear According to
some and yourself um listen the pope
recently said they completely accept
every gender identity and that everyone
is a children why should anyone be
compelled to use a pronoun from someone
who's changed their own identity three
times in three years want to go
back think it's very important to note
that other pop stars have done this
including Lou Capal who recently did a
campaign where he was naked on a
billboard and there were nowhere near as
many vile comments at leis kali's body
the only reason the only reason there's
a problem for Sam doing it is because
you aren't happy with his gender
identity because it makes you feel no I
don't care about his gender identity I
just don't feel I can be compelled to
use pronouns I don't care about that
that's fine don't use them if you don't
want to that's wrong but that's you just
told me I had to no I think you should
but if you don't want to decision PE
shut up I'm not Pi I'm modest man alive
right okay right so you're changing your
name now you're no longer about Sam
Smith is it's just an orgy of in my view
narcissistic self-indulgent deliberately
shocking stuff and Douglas has got point
he doesn't he looks terrible okay so why
would you do this you're friends with
ousie Osborne right and osie Osborne ate
a bat's head on stage that could be
considered vulgar I mean he basically
never did anything like this he started
the co pandemic serious about Sam Smith
getting their can't seriously think what
we're looking at here is actually
anything other than ridiculous no I
think it's absolutely F fantastic really
yeah I do I think it's brilliant I think
it's sexy I think it's inspir that is
and I that's someone exp you think what
we're looking at right now is sexy yes I
do you're both CIS white straight men
you can carry on I'm not sis anything
right I don't even know what
is you just want to both be when I was
BN just said I was assist what is
aist not what I'm here to discuss but
what
ient our skin color is now
relevant
White
you're not being racist and calling me
aissy or something hang on Pi Pi wait a
second what did he just say what did you
call us repeat it for Doug I said you
were both I can't remember to be honest
with you I think you said okay why
didn't you shut
up well dougas think you said that we're
both I I I think you said we're both CIS
white straight men first of all I am
white secondly I am a man thirdly I've
been out and gay my entire adult life
which is about 25 years now I don't know
how old you are
but I was I was out I was I was out as
gay when you were still prancing around
talking about whether or not you were so
do be quiet do stop judging other people
and if I were you judging are you joking
my God dou ridiculous I'm not the one
judging other people here I'm just
pointing out facts I'm sorry I got your
sexuality wrong no if I were you I would
do the tiniest bit of resarch before
opening your mouth you're embarrassing
yourself that's probably why people
would embarrassing yourself shame to the
que you know what I tell you who's
really embarrassing I'm not a m of
community stupid sod I'm not a member of
the queer Community the person who
ultimately is genuinely embarrassing
himself herself themsel whatever is Sam
Smith um on that note we'll leave it
thank you both very much with a picture
of sexy Sam I
you thank you very much James thank you
very much I'm glad we ended with such
Harmony it's been a very harmonious
evening
when online Tik Tok prankster mizy
became a social media sensation with his
decidedly antisocial stunts I invited
him into the studio for a little chat
fresh from the courtroom he's here now
all right well good evening to you hello
hello pz long time no see what do you
mean long time no see last time I CED on
your team with my friend oh that's right
you you appeared in the
background okay well I'm not your mate
um what I am what I am is interviewer
who I'm curious about what has been
motivating you to terrorize the people
around where you live why do it I
wouldn't really qu it terrorizing I'll
just call it more having fun you do
these things you take a dog from an
elderly woman you Leap Frog over the top
of an Orthodox Jewish man standing at
the side of the road minding his own
business you go up to women in the
street and say do you want to die it
wasn't a woman it was a man and she
there were also women that you women
there but I only say it to the man right
you shouldn't be saying it to anybody
fair enough why are you why in the name
of so-called prankster humor why cause
so much alarm and distress to so many
people do you get your kicks out of
doing that not necessarily but you can
say that this whole public outroar just
makes me laugh because people are
getting hurt over something that didn't
happen to them and that's how I see it
as what do you mean people are getting
hurt over something that didn't happen
to them everyone acts like they they
have this Persona like they don't care
or social media are facad this that the
other but when me comes out and does the
Mad thing everyone has something to say
a mad thing it's the Mad thing it's the
Mad thing you you already you already
said it was the Mad thing mad no it's
not mad it's moronic it's the kind of
thing anybody could do and you do it for
kicks and you do it for clicks and you
get your little moment on Tik Tok and
presumably your peer group that you
referenced earlier they all think good
on you good on you mzy this is hilarious
meanwhile some poor woman thinks you've
stolen her dog and is traumatized
another woman has a two kids and you're
bursting into their house uninviting
you're jumping on Jewish
people Jewish people hold up wait a
minute wait minute wait no no stop it
was a Jewish person cool but there was a
trend going around on Tik Tok called 30
I've done this to numerous people black
people white people age any types of
people I don't discriminate so don't
stop saying Orthodox dous person like I
only targeted him and it was only him
that I went for why are you targeting
anybody in that M well would you mean
why am I targeting anyone it was a trend
it was a trend I just done it for a
trend what's the trend what's the trend
30 jump over someone at the time of the
beat however much you scare them however
much you scare them I'm actually not
going to call you mzy CU it's it's
obviously a stage I'll call you barari
bronze right all right Bari bronze let's
try and talk to each other as human
beings right yeah I'm trying to
understand why there's no real remorse
here why do not why you mean consen I
went to go apologize off social media I
could have recorded that apology and
that would have been another viral video
whether it's hate or whatever literally
hate brings money hate brings likes hate
brings views it doesn't matter love or
hate it still brings views why would why
do you prefer to do the hateful stuff I
not like I prefer to do the hateful
stuff it's just like it's easier to do
the hateful stuff why you laughing and
obviously I don't think it's fun but
you're a funny person you do think it's
funny you're a funny person you do I've
seen the videos you do think it's just
really funny at the time I think it's
funny my fan base thinks it's funny and
it's we outside is it it's a movement
but what's the deep down what's the
movement deep down being free and not
letting anyone tell you nothing that's
why I can do all of this stuff I have
I'm the most hated person on the
internet right now no you're not done
Who You Are okay then whatever you say
in it whatever you say most people watch
this will have never heard of you and
care oh now they are that you just
bought it to me now they are they
they'll just look at the way you're
behaving now and they'll think yeah he's
a complete all right and you're a
complete you keep cutting me
interrupting me when I'm trying to talk
because you keep talking this animated
manner trying to stop me asking you any
questions and then you say is it because
I'm black is it somehow it's going back
to the race card why you going back to
that I said that once you mentioned it I
mentioned it once your skin color I
don't care what color you are if you
were white I'd have exactly the same
view about your moronic Behavior All
right but I'm curious who in your family
is there to tell you this is why you
need to go to my family I'm my own
person so talk about me no
no talk about me not my family yes but
here's the problem what's the problem
you are clearly a product of your
upbringing no I'm not I'm my own person
I've always been my own person I'm
you've had no one to tell you this is
wrong of course people have told me it's
wrong
family friends everyone's told me it was
wrong who told you wrong what do you
mean my own mother told me it was wrong
there's been situations between me and
my mom where so your mother doesn't like
what you're doing of I yeah so why did
you stop doing it CU my mother told me
to stop doing something that's your
mother you listen to your mother you
listen to somebody else I'm my own
person I'm I'm legally adult now so I
can do what I what are you going to do
now what am I going to do now Twitter m
is banned and I'm going to be on Twitch
yeah I'm going to start streaming on
Twitch IRL streams gaming streams my
twitch is mzy as live if you want to get
out that but yeah try and come up with a
sincere apology or not no I don't need
to come up with no sincere apology I
already have my own remorse and I
already I already you don't have any
what do you okay then whatever you you
it's all a bit of a j and if you steal
some old woman's dog it's all a bit of
fun if you jump on a Jewish man it's all
a bit of fun if you run into people's
houses with young kids and terrorize
them it's all a bit of fun what I'm
saying nothing really matters what I'm
saying to you is there's been plans to
change up everything and you you you're
just no help in it you just talk your
own thing you have your own set morals
and yeah so that's you no it's not about
morality I just think okay cool cool
whatever you say I was still talking I
was still talking you interrup me again
again Morgan why' you keep interrupting
let me tell you we're going to put both
of ourselves out of this misery and
we'll just end it there because you are
we should end as I said at the start
you're just a complete so until
you stop being you will be treated
like a you are M for the
record he wasn't paid for this obviously
um I feel is that she just put up with
it welcome back to my 12 ding-dongs of
Christmas we're counting down the
biggest of the bares and bus dos we've
had on uncensored in
2023 at number 10 a meaty debate between
a chef who banned vegans and an activist
who got very hangry about it all but I'm
joined now by the vegan Banner himself
John mountain and here in the studio
animal rights activist Joey carbstrong
well welcome to both of you okay John
Mountain why did you ban vegans from
your
restaurant uh morning Pierce I banned
them from my restaurant because look
I've been a chef for nearly 30 years but
on this particular incident it was just
too much you know they grouped together
which you know I'm very proud of the
vegans for all sticking together but
they did they grouped and banded
together and then started hammering my
business with one star reviews I saw my
rating drop from a sensible 4.2 down to
2.8 they they nearly broke me God bless
the vegans though he he made a statement
saying uh the vegans are angry and angry
but he carried on and banned all vegans
from his restaurant because of one
simple complaint he's allowed to yeah
he's allowed to ban a whole group of
people from a chef who's just sick of
tailoring to vegan people who want to
have all this stuff and I don't walk
around with a dead baby pigs facing them
like that like does that look like
someone who really gives a damn about
animals like you know and he profile
picture looking at a dead pig in austr
in Australia one second I just want to
say this in Australia pigs are killed in
gas Chambers okay they cause pigs
they're horrible have you seen footage
from inside a gas chamber I recently
exposed one in the UK they scream to
death and beg for mercy in per there's a
gas chamber called linle Valley pork
right and this guy serves pork at his
restaurants and why would you be more
upset that of a little complaint as a
shed than pigs being murdered in okay
let me ask you the question that I asked
a vegan activist the other day which is
that given that uh 80% or 90% of the
world's armens come from California
where they are made in the involving the
demolition of billions of bees who get
murdered how do you feel about the
little don't get murdered and that's
completely false and I don't know why
how many billions how many billions of
be die in in the pollination I've got
the 2022 data right here they die mostly
from parasites and pest 66% die of
varites or other pests and parasites die
from disease in the making excuse me arm
and avocados they don't oh they do they
do the dang is here it's this here you
here dat from US Department of
Agriculture you know where I read this I
read it in the guardian the vegan Bible
even the guardian admitted that he V who
eat avocados 6.7% this is not don't care
about the little guys it's not what
we're about I think each should be to
their own and you should just enjoy your
life you know if they're going to argue
Pi I enjoy your but Joey why can't
killing animals look at this with a
murdered ping with Mur and it wasn't you
can't handle a simple complaint from a
and this woman she's a very nice young
woman spoke to this young woman she's
very nice very kind very polite and you
can't handle a s ask celebrity sh and
it's clear even me is complain about his
restaurant he doesn't ban all me to be
if you want to be a vegan I don't care
right it's entirely down to you about
bees they're not being slaughtered
billions of bees everyone going millions
of are getting killed by here say to
everyone to everyone watching this
either on the show tonight or on YouTube
later go and Google bees US Department
of Agriculture St avocados and you'll
see the truth this is a gas chamber
Pierce this is how pigs are killed and
slaughtered in the UK this is my
investigation question why don't you
play me why don't you play me the sound
of billions of bees being
murdered I know that animals get killed
like can eat PE they're screaming to
death right look at them face them what
do you think bees do them what do you
think bees do when you murder them they
get killed by m this is gas chamber look
at it you don't want to look at it they
geted you're cow cowardly I love bacon
you promote it you say you're against
anal I love sausages I love it all I
love eating meat you love animal cruelty
yeah I'm prepared to admit I love eating
meat you're not prepared to denounce
avocado and arm because you're making up
St don't get because they actually lead
to termination milons of John final word
to
you final word is how many vegans does
it take to change a light bulb go
on none they all wait for the punch line
what's the punch line none what go have
a cry made about prefer to stay in the
dark go have a cry actually the other
one I like is how do you know when
someone's vegan don't worry gas chamber
footage don't worry they'll soon tell
you and play pictures and stuff of
people screaming being murdered in gas
well they won't play you is bees being
murdered Joey see John thank you for
joining me from Perth
I
with Ukraine unable to play host City
because of the war Liverpool welcomed
Eurovision 2023 a calls for joy and
celebration well not for
me Eurovision returns to the UK this
week after 25 year absence supposed to
be of course in Ukraine who won it last
time but uh obviously Ukraine can't host
it so Liverpool has the dubious honor of
being host City uh and that's fine and
everyone I know seems to be wildly
excited about this apart from me because
I think Eurovision is a stain on
Humanity oh ridiculous now the first of
two semi-finals was afflicted on
audiences last nighte of the Grand Final
on Saturday Fans Say Eurovision is a
world- class Festival of the Arts an
exhibition of the best that pop music
can offer Recollections may vary take a
look at
[Music]
this IU
my I got on my head my Sharp and my eyes
are are we are we are go
[Music]
bab that last that we called we are the
winners from Lithuania the one thing
Lithuania has never won is anything um
unbelievable I'm going to bring in now
Sharon Osborne and Louis well Sharon's
with me Louis's wherever Louis is at the
per we're going to try and he's an
irland of course he is they're going to
try and persuade me that this ludicrous
f is actually a credible tournament
Louie you go first try come on I say
it's awful listen I watched the
semi-final last night I know you do but
I think it's brilliant fun I watch it
every single year there are some really
good songs you played all the bad ones
but there's some ABA came from
Seline Dion Johnny Logan so many great
people it's light entertainment at its
best pier and you may not like it but I
love it I think it's honestly Shar I bet
Sharon well the thing is it doesn't
surprise me you like it when we did
America's Got Talent together you always
put the Nutty acts like that through and
it was down to me on behalf of the
Grateful American people to buzz them
off you love this crap I I do it's not
crap it's cultural because it's not
cultural is it's very interesting to see
all these different cultures and what
they consider to be entertainment and
it's very interesting look a little you
know the worst thing about it and I'm
going to say this is somebody who went
to Ukraine to interview president
zalinski and his and his wife and I've
obviously done a lot of stuff about the
Ukraine war I really didn't like Ukraine
winning it last year simply because the
country is at War and I don't and I'm
sure they're going to probably win it
again this year for the same reason the
moment any competition to me goes into
what I call called just transparent
virtue signaling they weren't the best
act we all know that oh Behave of course
they then it's not a competition it's
something else it's like it's people
just ticking boxes no it's people that
like other people peers and try and
understand that you know the worst thing
Louie I I when I went to Ukraine I came
through the train station to go back to
Poland and the train station manager
gave me the hat that the winner of the
Ukraine that that hat he gave it to the
train station guy in Kei and signed it
and he and the guy gave it to me uh and
obviously it was the last thing I want I
had to pretend I had to pretend to be
happy you should have put it on for a
picture let's not pretend that Ukraine
that look I love Ukraine I love
ukrainians I want them to win this War I
don't want to see them keep winning
competitions simply because they're at
War it's ridiculous they only won last
year I mean I voted for them maybe 10
times last year I wanted them to win
because was was pretty good all right so
should they should they win the football
World Cup as then they should win
everything should they yes yes okay L
peers it was a good song we listen to
the songs Sharon and I are in the music
business it was a good it wasn't a good
song it wasn't a good song it was I
haven't heard a good song onion I would
say since Abba when was Abba 1970
something
right Seline Dion Johnny Logan Buck Fizz
loads of people
I watched last night there some amazing
you're cting bux fiz I thought I thought
that Switzerland was good did you like
Switzerland
Louie I did but I loved Finland I know
he's a bit crazy but I loved it I also
loved Israel I thought was
absolutely here my problem with my other
problem with it is it's a complete
Carver where all the countries basically
look after their mates none of it none
of the Voting is genuine they'll often
take the best song and itate it because
it's not from a country that's part of
the Pierce you are wrong the best song
Always Wins always yeah but the bar is
unbelievably low a the bar is
unbelievably low for that title and B
the best song never wins but it's about
entertainment peers it's about
personality pres presentation all of
that well let's say this this this is
the UK entry this year haven't listened
to some of
this yeah I
know about how you did me wrong I could
have cried at home and spent the night
alone instead I wrote a song
[Music]
I just please stop that look this is my
point this is my point about that that
is that you hear that in every Euro
trash disco at 3 in the morning when
they want people to leave they turn on
that kind of stuff when they want to
kick people out she represent you of
today you of today there's not a person
under 50 who would listen to that and
not think it's horrifying you're wrong
it's for it's for 0y old guys and their
bimbo Mistresses to go and dance at some
nightclub in Lithuania at 3 in the
morning that's what that's for no and
the idea that you two who do actually
know your music this is what offends me
you married to one of the great rock
stars in history weaned rock music your
father one of the great Rock managers
and you Louis W produce some of the
great pop bands of all time the fact
that you have straight faces because
it's do you try and persuade me that
this garbage is serious music I love
it sound Rider one he so do I it's
entertainment I
do are you both going to watch the whole
thing absolutely you're going to watch
it are you proud absolutely Louie what
about Island not getting
through no it wasn't great it wasn't
great it wasn't great oh really there
was a song that your Orion that wasn't
great
yeah there there are some great songs
neither of you believe a words saying AB
you do this kind of thing to annoy
people like me who really gifted musical
ear no no it's not it's about makes
people happy this is why I had to be the
lead judge on America's Got oh boo
because Sharon would go nuts and put
these sort of Acts through and I would
have to then save the
nation peers there's a massive Market
150 million people can't be wrong they
can and they are the whole thing is a
complete travesty it's a travesty the
production is Sensational BBC have done
a great
job amazing amazing
un it's it's not just the songs we watch
for the clothes the dancing all the
outrage that goes you don't know what's
going to Happ differ all right just just
play me a little bit be played at the
start please this is It's the clo it's
the music it's the whole the whole
ensemble let's remind ourselves of that
it's everything here we
[Music]
go I mean honestly in a court of law
this is the moment that Ron pole of the
Bailey goes I rest my case literally I
rest my case I've got to leave it there
thank God two years ago no no there's no
more years ago you you've had a you both
had a chance to me has spectacularly
failed it is utter nonsense I will not
be anywhere near a TV on Saturday
night that's it will no won no Louie
lovely to see you though and Sharon
lovely to see you always a pleasure
never a CH and I know that off camera
you'll both say to me you know what
you're right but that's what normally
happens that's the problem that's the
problem I keep it real not this
time sharing the number eight slot on
the countdown ex labor leader Jeremy
Corbin and next Chancellor quasi quaten
warning their close friends and family
might want to look away now you've never
said sorry for what happened a year over
year ago what I've said I bear
responsibility for it why not say sorry
you haven't condemned what her Mass did
on October the 7th have you of course I
have on every speech and do you
unreservedly condemn at every speech
I've made have utterly condemned the
killing of October the 7th and it was a
taking of innocent life it was totally
wrong under any circumstances I'm really
curious why you've never been able to
bring yourself to say the simple words
I'm sorry after all the damage that was
inflicted by that ruinous 44-day regime
of Liz truss and I'm sure that you would
say and we come to this a lot of it was
on her no I'm not here to a portion
blame I mean that's the that's one of
the reasons you take responsibility for
that's one of the reasons why I get it
if you take if you take responsibility
why are you also not prepared to say
sorry so I think there's a it sounds
like a loyaly distinction but I think
there's a difference the question then
becomes how do you get rid of them now
my question for you is do you agree Hass
has to go look I don't support Hass I'm
not a friend of aass I don't agree you
used to call them friends no hang on we
did you're no Ken let's get this clear
we did say that can you hang on a second
let me just is that not true there were
lots of other people involved in this
okay there was I'm not a Chancellor I'm
not going to take sole responsibility uh
when there were lots of not taking any
responsibility if you heard the Elton
John song Sorry seems to be the it's a
it's a you like that it's it's a very
good song you play it a lot uh I'm not a
big fan of Elon John but I like you know
that song yeah yeah yeah I do I do know
that song do those words resonate you
are obsessed obsessed with titl tattle
of politics of something that happens 10
years ago why don't you why don't you
instead con people supporting her let me
finish give me a chance let meish no
well look I'm not coming here to
relitigate you spent 10 minutes not
wanting to apologize um and you you
spent the year not wanting to apologize
no I've said I've said millions of times
I bear responsibility that we should
have we did things uh in the wrong way
but in terms of the strategy I still
believe in the strategy would you keep a
mass in power you wouldn't answer they
wouldn't be can you not speak for him
it's not a puppet show it's not a puppet
show L it's not a puppet show he's
allowed to answer for himself of course
he is well let him answer the reality is
let him answer the reality is jery all
you want to do is bully people who am I
bullying you're bullying constantly
there two of you okay one's run the a
party in the country one's on a major
Union are you really feeling bullied let
do me a favor do me a bloody fa do me a
bloody favor have you ever apologize for
anything yeah I mean I apologize in my
private life the whole time when was the
last time you apologized for something I
think um I think I picked up my daughter
from nurs uh too late and I apologize
then a couple of weeks so just to be
clear hang on just to be clear you're
happy to apologize to people hang on at
a nursery school for being a few minutes
late to pick up your daughter but you're
not prepared to apologize
to milons of people for screwing their
personal finances can I put it this way
would you get rid
of answer my question no can I say
something would you get rid of her Mass
can I say yes or no thank you and I've
never been one for saying you know if as
a politician um you know you're
personally um damaging people there's
there's policy there's
debate well no because there were lots
of other things I did not personally
damage those people I You' admitted the
implementation your there was a lot of
cont bad it there was a lot of context
as well you said well forget about the
context well no the context is important
I know the context I saw the reaction to
your policy and I think that yeah and
there was a white there was a there were
lots of things going on there was also
the time where um I came back from
Washington and was sacked and and you
know I haven't asked for apology for
that that's the way uh public affairs uh
these days is conducted so my question
again and just answer this question
would you keep herass in power it's not
up to you what's your opinion you're
plenty of other opinions aren't you can
can you calm down a minute can I ask you
question you I'm Sor calm down a minute
if you think a match should stay in
power Cal can I ask you well I wanted to
answer the question can I ask no he can
answer it can I ask you a question it's
not a puppet show lens you're sorry
right and you're sorry for the damage
the
implementation so there you go you know
we've had this discussion I think you're
right to say on consideration I think
you're right to say people should put
their hand up and also having put their
hand up they should be able to show some
Contrition and and I'm happy I'm happy
to show that why would't you say her go
you are a very strange form of
interviewing am I where you interrupt
shout and abuse your guest well you
refuse to answer my question and he
keeps trying to answer it for you look
if you want to have a discussion fine if
you want to just shout at me that's your
prog your TV your show should have man
stay in power listen what I said was a
ceasefire means a ceasefire it means
both sides have to cease for it means
you then now you said that should have
Master stay in
power it's actually you're done yet it's
actually a critical question done it's a
critical question you're done no it's
the question am I right in thinking you
now for the damage that the
implementation caused to millions of
people you're sorry I I I I show abject
uh Contrition I'm very are you sorry
look look whatever formula of words I
I'm just asking are you sorry I'm sorry
um the turbulence that the that was
caused you're sorry for the damage it
calls to British people if if if that's
what you want me to say no it's what I
want you to want to say why can't you
have a discussion about how a ceasefire
would come about why can't you have a
discussion about a process for the
future because you know why which brings
abouty which brings about a peace for
everybody when I repated it does not
mean that the people of Gaza when I
repeatedly support Hamas when I
repeatedly ask you are Hamas a terror
organization and should they stay in
power and you are simply incapable of
saying that they're a terror group and
they shouldn't stay people will draw
their own conclusions they draw their
own you your conclusions before anyway
conclude with this uh you've done a book
on
poetry poetry for the many I appreciate
it thank you very much wonderful poetry
from wonderful people encouraging the
working classes to embrace and enjoy
culture poetry and music for the many I
love poetry we can agree on that what I
want to say is that I think the strategy
was right I'm sorry for the
implementation are you sorry for the
damage caused to the British I'm sorry
for the implementation and it was it was
too far to and for the damage caused to
the British I don't know why you look
there were lot because they suffered
Financial people were lots of people
were but no but you were the chancellor
okay I was the chancellor ex check are
you sorry for the financial damage it
caused to the British people sorry for
the uh damage and the loss and uh and it
was a scary time and I'm sorry for that
quazi we got there okay and I've not
tried to drag that out of you that's
fair
enough
[Music]
for seven on a list my head-to-head
encounter with chess grandmas Hans nean
young Hans has been accused of bending
the rules throughout his career as ever
I was determined to get to the very
bottom of the controversy well I'm
joined Now by Hans Neeman and by his
lawyer Terren oi so first question Hans
for you why have you got got your lawyer
with you well uh considering the the
recent uh case and settlement uh some
legal questions I'm you know my my
lawyer might be able to better answer
and uh to be honest uh I'm you know uh
Terry and uh his team has been frankly
you know great in in in helping me
resolve this case and uh I'm very very
thankful to them for believing in me and
uh you know this is not just a he's not
just my lawyer he's he's a friend he's a
confidant and he's someone uh who I
trust uh fully and uh that's why he's
here today I don't like people that
cheat in any form of competitional sport
because to me it just kills the
integrity and purity of it and I guess
you would agree with that
right no of course so but you should
understand you know the difference
between when you're you know young child
and you're under severe pressure and and
and you make a mistake and you know you
should also understand that uh when it
comes to over theboard official
tournaments I've never cheated and
there's absolutely no evidence that I've
ever cheated but here's the problem
here's the problem with that I I like I
said when you're 12 all right I get it
but to do the same thing again when
you're 16 shows there's a pattern and we
only we only actually have your word for
it right I mean there might not be hard
evidence to have nailed you but you can
understand why people be suspicious
given your emissions Pi we understand
Hans was 16 years old he made a mistake
we understand that you have a different
uh interpretation he was playing online
in a game that really didn't matter at
at a young age we understand and you're
not wrong but to try to extrapolate from
the fact of something that he did on an
online game when he was 16 and say once
a cheater always a cheater if you did
something when you were 16 I'm going to
hold it against you for the rest of your
life we think that's a little harsh and
it certainly doesn't properly
characterize of all right but why
couldn't he answer that
question I think he was trying to well
no was sorry yeah H it was really aimed
at you you know if you cheat in a sport
once well I got say let me well I can
give you analogy as well so let's say
that you know you know you know a
16-year-old kid went into like a pickup
basketball game that is the equivalent
of the games that I treated in at 16
years old is the equivalent of a
meaningless pickup basketball game do
you think that that should should Define
my entire career especially using you're
using you know computerized systems to
some way of to make moves in chess I
can't think of a more egregious way of
cheating than doing that you're using a
non-human brain to beat a human I me
it's just it's FR he did not do that
here but he didn't he did not do that
here meaning what he did back then what
he did about 5 years ago and then about
10 years ago you're correct he he's he's
admitted that and he's apologized for
that yeah but that has absolutely
nothing to do with what happened here
any nothing else could be closer to the
truth so you yesterday I believe you
played Vladimir kramnick on chess.com uh
and you beat him and cnick said said
afterwards I've decided to stop playing
on chess.com from from tomorrow on just
too many obvious cheaters on here and
nothing is done to clean the platform
from these small Crooks harsh words but
true what what did you make of
that well the Crick situation is quite
complex because I actually beat him
about a week ago and uh he made a video
that was a bit confusing but um actually
a couple days ago I had private
correspondence with him where he told me
that he has personally has no issue with
me and where he said that uh he was not
meant to be an accusation whatsoever
so uh what was it supposed to be it
couldn't have been a more blatant
suggestion that you cheated again well
that contradicts you know the direct you
know the the private correspondents and
email that he sent to me and why would
he infer your a cheat in public in the
way that he did that was yesterday well
he in he but he he he my name was never
mentioned you know he accused a lot of
people of cheating he's
accused yeah but he's he's he played
that same day he played against you know
10 other people and considering ing that
I was invited by him to Amsterdam to
meet him and to play games with him um
it seems a bit weird uh that you know
that he would do that you know and then
the next day supposedly accused me of
cheating so you know I understand that
how it might look but uh you know he's
privately reached out to me and I was
invited to Amsterdam I unfortunately
can't go um due to another conflict but
I hope to meet him and to discuss things
in more detail with him okay you sued um
isn't that the real damage of this also
Pierce isn't that the real damage as
well so whenever now someone to beat
someone than acknowledge it and say that
I'll get better now this is set a
precedent that whenever someone beats
you inad of try try to take it away from
them yes but unfortunately actions have
consequences if you admit you've cheated
twice Over a four-year period uh and you
become a grand master the year after the
second time and you now only 20 now
people are going to obviously C
dispersions why you focus on those two
isolated incidents why don't you focus
on two aded w they the two your clients
admitted to of course but the other the
the other hundreds of matches that he's
won are those totally meaningless so you
can always focus on the shade I don't
know I don't the majority I'm not
judging your client I'm just saying he's
admitted to cheating twice Over a
four-year period and that's why maybe
people are in meaningless games you know
I mean people do wonder how did you beat
they do wonder how did you beat Magnus
Carlson um okay if you want to take that
logic you know you want to take that
logic right so I have proven my strength
right chess.com themselves have said
that since I you know since they gave me
a short band before they said that since
then I have never cheated so on their
website I've beaten some of the best
players in the world I've performed at
the highest level on their website which
they they themselves say that I I didn't
cheat in in addition to that in over
theboard tournaments I have continued to
play Chess at a very very high level I
have you know you know my ranking my
ranking did not just drop I continued to
play well even after this Victory I
proven my my chest level and my chest
strength time and time again this is
simply a case of of you know where
Bullies Are are you know going after
someone because they threaten their
business interests you should looking at
fact that of course he's a bully he used
his entire Empire he used his
connections to chess.com he leveraged
his you know the fact that there's a you
know a merger happening and he got all
these people to attack me and it was
it's a bully it's a simple thing but you
know I don't you know let people bully
me I'm going to stand up to him and I
stood up to him and you know I look
forward to competing him against the
board again and uh you know I'm going to
you know do what I do best and and prove
myself are you stilling are you still
suing him for $100
million no you dropped
that the case has been resolved Pierce
yeah did did he corre did did he pay any
money
or we can't discuss
that okay out of Interest how do you how
do you disprove that you you've used
anal beads to
cheat Ian how can I you know prove just
prove a negative it's it's like how do
you expect me that was never a a serious
thing that was something that the media
caught up but that was you know if you
if you look at the the consensus among
chess players the consensus among
experts it is an unequivocal fact that I
have never cheated in an over theboard
game yeah behind I'm just wondering how
do you disprove it I mean were you strip
search did they explore cavities where
do we go here
well through tournaments there are
security checks where they you know will
do you know various Security checks you
know metal detectors different scanners
um would that pick up anal be
you I I don't know Pierce I have no you
should invite them on your show you
should you should invite them on your
show and ask them that it appears that
that's the main topic of your curiosity
appears to be that as opposed to the
fact that you have a 19-year-old
champion who defeated a champion ion who
defeated the whole world of Chess in the
largest cyber bullying case in history
the world of Chess versus Hans nean and
he's here to talk about it and he's
still a Victor and instead of becoming
bitter he became better and you want to
ask him about the anal bead something he
never said or never did we don't know
the answer to that question piis maybe
you can ask the anal be people have them
on your show and they can explain it to
you better I think I will because it's
actually a fc listen I love chess I was
my school my Prep School CH anal beads
better at Pi well I was my Prep School
chess champion I never Che
you're a better person you're a better
person you your words not mine
Terrence but I'm just I'm genuinely
curious it was a massive story as you
know it's why you're famous outside of
uh the Chess World is because there was
this allegation made and it was fueled
by the world champion who couldn't
understand how in normal circumstances
you would beat him uh and then came M he
lost many people of my same ranking many
times so this idea that it's a
statistical anomaly he can lose one game
and and that's the issue right he lost
to people similar age similar rating
multiple times recently so me beating
him in a singular game is not a
statistical anomaly right he hasn't
agreed to play you as I understand it is
he is he chickening out what's the deal
there no he has agreed to play me he put
out a public statement that he he will
play there's no date right so well when
it when we are matched in a tournament
which which is inevitable uh uh uh we
will play and will you allow yourself to
be strip searched just to roll out any
rumors I find that question to be just
you know I can't take you seriously when
you ask those questions Pierce I'm sorry
because you're you're entertaining uh uh
honestly an allegation that should
should not even be taken seriously
because it's it's purely you know for
you know for you to get media attention
when this when this is it's not even a
serious thing how can how can you as a
reporter take that allegation seriously
at all well I no but I know do you
genuinely believe that no but do you
know do you actually believe that that
that is the case I don't know could you
could you even fa I don't know I know
you're capable of cheating cuz you've
admitted it I don't know how far you go
you cheated twice in a four I've never
cheated in an over theboard game I've
never well I'm clearly not I'm not
capable and I've never cheat over
theboard games we only have your words
for that you accept that right we have
your words for my word it's unequivocal
chess.com themselves said that right it
is an unequivocal statistical fact that
I have never cheated an over theboard
game and that is something you cannot
debate Elon Musk as you know tweeted uh
on what was known as Twitter then is now
Talent hits a Target no one else can hit
genius hits a Target no one can see cuz
it's in your butt what did you feel when
you read
that well I was a bit surprised um you
know uh I was surprised uh you know I
didn't really think much of it you know
I I focus on competing and um I don't
let these things affect me and uh my
goal is to become the best chess player
in the world and and and to give back to
chess players all around the world and
uh I think that chess is a beautiful
game that should be spread and that's
why I intend to do a lot more charity
work and give back to the communities
who who helped me do you think when you
play Magnus Carson again you'll kick his
butt for one of a better
phrase you know I'll just let my chest
PE for
itself H nean and Terrence your lawyer
thank you both very much
indeed thank you Hans nean the bad boy
of
chess